hello everyone I'm joined by my good
friend Richard you gotta love who is a
celebrity photographer and videographer
and he's joining me today to talk about
the seven steps that you need to take in
order to make amazing YouTube videos
without spending a lot of money ok so
what's step one so step one is you want
to figure out the camera you're going to
use to record yourself so you can use
pretty much at the beginning you don't
know if you're going to like this you
know if you're going to continue on
doing it so you don't want to spend 2 3
5 grand on setting up outfitting your
equipment so start with what you have
whether it's a cell phone camera or an
old video camera or anything that's
digital can easily be converted or can
be input to your computer for editing
and for posting so start with anything
that you have that's good enough and
preferably hopefully it's got HD quality
which most stuff does now I started my
first videos with my DSLR canon camera
and then went to my flip there's that
some of the still around the flips went
to the flip and then I got a camcorder
from costco and I kept upgrading a
costco because they had a generous
return policy yeah so Henry's and other
stores it gives you like seven days and
they've got to bring it back we're
costco like a try return at try it
returned it and I eventually got a
camcorder so neat no sony handycam yeah
so what it is sony handycam have one of
those for like 400 bucks and costco and
then i use that for over a year before
upgrading to the next level and so yeah
I totally agree you start with what you
have a lot of people feel like I can't
get started because I don't have the
right gear that's just in your head get
started get site with what you have
right now so what are you using to shoot
this right now right now we're using my
DSLR which is a canon 5d and I've got
really nice lens on it that i use for
portraiture for for photography and it's
a beautiful 85 1.2 so it's super bright
super fast lens and that that's my
favorite that's what i'm using right now
yeah we can also do this on your camera
and here i've got my my little samsung
camera already ready to record and it's
in selfie mode so that it's a lesser
quality camera than the back camera and
we're just going to press for core here
we go so this is what this camera looks
like this is us
on camera yeah and this is this is good
enough quality to start yeah just get
started and you can do it like this the
only thing is now your hand holding it
so maybe you want to figure out a way to
you know something to put it on maybe
some selfie stick or a tripod that can
hold a cell phone a lot to manage if
your hand holding you might want to
consider putting it on a tripod such
from something people but quality is
good enough don't let it hold you back
yeah so what's step number two step
number two is sound it's so important to
get good sound because if the picture is
decent but the sound sucks no one's
gonna watch it there can't hear it they
can't engage yeah so and you don't want
to go out and spend a few hundred
dollars on a mic and then learn how to
set it up so you could use your onboard
sound that means it sound that the
microphone that comes on the camera
you're using or even on the cell phone
but now the only thing that you can
control since you can't control that
Mike you can control the environment so
you want to make sure you're at a space
that is actually quiet that won't have a
dog running around or someone honking
their horn or you know or music playing
all of a sudden you want to be able to
have a quieter space so whether that's
like here in nature or if it's a room in
a house that you know is going to be
quiet or anything like that that the
sound is controlled yeah when I first
started that was the number one
complaint that I got was the sound
quality I was just talking into the
camera or talking into like my webcam
yeah here we're using we have a clip
Mike that that we're kind of sharing
it's on me but kind of pointed this way
yeah take a chair when I do my normal
videos I've got a mic as well now but
when i first started growing the the
first investment that I made the reason
why I went for the higher end the hiring
four hundred dollar costco camera was
because it had an external microphone
jack so that i can go to sony store I
bought a $90 clip Mike and it just made
a huge difference I think most of the
cameras now should have a external
microphone jack yeah but that that was a
number one complaint yeah so even now
I'll still record videos on my iPad
where I'm walking on the street and a
number of you guys commented that what
are you using the sounds it sounds
really good and so I think the devices
are getting a lot a lot a lot better be
on the pick up sound as long as it's not
too much Wayne their car noises or
airplanes overhead here we've got birds
in the background in Miami the
occasional airplane going over but it's
not it's not being picked up as much
because we have
the clip mic so the first investment
that I made after getting the camera was
getting that $90 external clip might
because it really makes a big difference
on the sound quality so what's number
three number three I would say a third
consideration is a background you want
to make sure that the background is not
distracting and is actually
complementary looks nice so whether here
we chose this background although it's
rather busy but because the lens of God
going on we have extra control because
of the equipment we're using so I can
make the background go out of focus and
it actually becomes a really nice shot
because we're in focus and the
backgrounds all just colors and lights
and out of focus bouquet but if you
don't have that and for most of people
starting out they won't have that my
recommendations to start with the
background that's just a blank wall so
going into your home your office or some
interior environment where there's just
a blank wall and if that doesn't exist
then take a room that's got stuff on the
walls but go to an art shop you can buy
this it looks like it's like a bristol
board that's that's taped on to a foam
core it's called foam core white foam
core they also sell black foam core you
could buy big four foot by eight foot
piece for twenty bucks at an art shop
you can even buy smaller piece so for 10
15 bucks you can have a great background
and just set it up behind you or you can
even you can even know just paint apart
if you're that dedicated you're up to
doing it just paint a little square
behind you on the wall somewhere that
you can control this way you have a nice
simple background yeah when I started my
videos there are always on a blank wall
for the most part when I shoot myself
and it was just a white wall in my
office yeah that was it and now most of
the viewers that I shoot myself are on
the office that I have now and I painted
my wall black nice and then I had my
logo which is block printed off and it's
just a one of those removable stickers
that I have on the wall so if you ever
watch some of the hangouts you'll see
the big black believe in the black wall
behind me and my wife thought it was
crazy at the first like why are you
painting the wall black we don't want a
block wall here but not you think it
looks good yeah and you know what to add
to that you're going to paint the wall
use the dullest flattest most matte
paint you can
the paint will reflect light which will
make it really less less pleasant so
make it really flat or matte and their
thing about backgrounds the reason you
don't want to just hand hold it and walk
around is because the background is so
distracting that we as the viewer will
watch you and well economy will get
distracted from your message because
we're looking at the pretty background
behind you the people walking by or the
birds or the sky or there's snow
whatever might be so it's better to have
a really simple background so that the
focus is on you and your message rather
they're getting distracted with
everything else that's going on we've
used this background right here because
I could blur it and bouquet so you have
really nice backdrop you can't really
tell what it is except the ministries
it's not distracting the focus is more
on heaven dancing so it works but had we
have chosen another background here
which he's not really in the Sun but
it's a little bit busy still know the
eye he's going to that lamp on the on
the right side and it's going to all the
bricks Evans dancing is awesome it's
going to the bricks there's too much
going on to this background which we
could have also used right there now
we've got Evan right in the Sun
squinting really not looking that great
plus we also have you know a house in
the background it's not as interesting
and there's windows there's too much
going on so what's step number four step
number four is lighting you want to make
sure you're well lit which means
Pleasant light all over your face so
there's no hard shadows so how do you do
that and also the color of the light
also matters so right now being outside
in ambient light meaning no direct
sunlight so that's the perfect lightly
you can get because then the light is
very soft and it's always filling it
fills your face and the color is right
as well it's all one color so how do you
manage that out or indoors indoors I
would say either bring a light to put in
front of the camera like just one light
source a soft light or or maybe take a
lamp and have it facing you from the
front overhead lights are also good the
only thing is depending on where you
stand with the overhead light it might
call
or casting really nasty shadows so you
want to try to get a light in front of
you or another thing you could do is
just stand in front of a window like
Evan here used to do stand in front of a
window with softer light so no direct
sunlight on your face and that's really
great to do it it just really my points
man i got i will add something here come
on he was there so I took it see I might
one of my very first videos i did on PT
Barnum and I was so happy because I
borrowed a friend's camcorder to shoot
it but I did it in front of a windows
the window behind me and and I thought
oh because I need to get light in on me
right you're supposed to do it with the
window there and I was so dark and all
you could see was outside and so from
that video on I always just tried to
face a window so there's light on me and
it may not be the most advanced
technique and some of my friends in the
video editing world you're like oh come
on you need to have a setup and lights
and soft boxes and all of this stuff and
I mean that could help but just standing
in front of a window makes a huge
difference and I did that for years when
I was certain my channel now in my
office when I'm filming on the black
wall I have one overhead light and just
two lamps that I point not soft boxes
just I'll and some ikea with with soft
light and kind of pointed up at the
ceiling so it bounces instead of being
right on me yeah so what's up number
five step number five is editing so what
has a beginner where you can do for
editing is use what you have on your
computer most computers come with a
simple editing format or editing
software so yeah on a Mac you got like
iMovie or movie maker on a PC or
Camtasia all that stuff so use those for
editing they're usually drag and drop
very simple keep it simple what I would
say is edit out all pro long pauses
where there's nothing said or edit out
arms and oz or or searching for words
edit those things out make it really
tight or as tight as you can also edit
out where you repeat yourself because we
tend to repeat yourself right we'll have
like the same point set three times and
slightly different words so as you're
editing you're watching it you're
listening to it be aware of what you're
saying repetitively that you can maybe
cut out because it makes it much better
for the viewer just to see it shorter
and get the point once rather than being
undated with the same
yeah I love it I think editing saves you
because if you make a mistake you just
keep going right a lot of this this
video was probably like ten times longer
than what is actually released because
we made mistakes and had blue person had
some fun and ran away from bees and that
1i camera and so like if you make
mistake it's okay just keep going and
you can cut and edit it out I started
using movie maker this free with Windows
you're actually pretty powerful and easy
to understand program it does all the
basics that you need I have stepped it
up to Camtasia somewhere why probably
about a year in and then after that I
turned it over to an editor to help me
with but super valuable cut out you're
cut out your arms like I just made it um
you know you can cut out the repeats cut
out the bloopers but I'd like adding
those in at the end you know a little
little blooper some fun at the end and
also lets you make a cool intro and
extra don't worry about being that the
best editor in the world because the
most important thing is going to be your
message and getting that out and having
something powerful to say on camera so
step number six is get a team now rich
is is lucky enough to be able to have
all the skills himself to do the
recording and editing because that's
what he does for me I've had to build up
a team because I think what's important
is to figure out what you're really good
at where you can shine and focus your
strengths on that and not do the things
that you suck at our weekend because if
you're only spending ten percent of your
time are the things that you're really
really good at and ninety percent doing
stuff that you're mediocre at then
you're never going to be able to do
anything great with your videos and so
the first person that I hired for my
team was an editor and that allowed me
to go from making one video a week to
like seven videos a week because I could
just be in front of the camera I still
shot everything myself and then give it
to her just send it through dropbox and
everything else magically happen right
she would post it too so Christina now's
my full-time editor she'll post it to my
youtube channel she'll name it she'll
add the thumbnail all that stuff that I
can contribute to but it's not my core
strengths we've expanded to now I have
her husband Sam helping me on the
editing too so we've got one and a half
editors the second person I hired was
Ivan who helped me do a lot of the
research for my videos especially the
top ten in the end stress of videos that
is an insane amount of research finding
clips to be able to put on the channel
and that allowed me to go from seven
videos a week to 14 to 21 videos a week
right so now I'm just shooting me I'm
doing the best that I can and I've
gotten people onto helping with
everything else I have a videographer
who comes in once a week and I shoot my
videos normally on a Wednesday and he
just gives me the files and I senator
Christina and now Nina's helping with
the comments because i have so many
comments coming in that I can't keep up
myself with him so it's ivan christina
sam nina and Jason and me so it's six
people on my team to make this channel
happen that's awesome so good in about
any problem to have yeah but it started
with the editor because that's what I
wasn't great at step number seven so
that is consistency like everything else
you can't just start and drop it and
hope to get better at it you started
just keep going keep going for a while
until you know for sure that either
you're not going to do it or you know
for sure that you are going to do it but
keep consistent until that point so pump
out videos all the time don't get
stopped get outside your head don't
criticize yourself you're going to suck
at the beginning but you're gonna get
better everything's gonna get better the
picture will with sound well and and so
will the quality the video what do you
have to say yeah I think this is one of
the most important lessons for people
going to start on youtube because at the
start you're all excited you got energy
i'm going to be a youtuber you get your
videos up and you look at them when you
hate them and maybe you don't post it
and then you do post some and they don't
get a lot of views nobody's commenting
and then you post more and there's still
not a lot of views or comments and you
start to feel discouraged like why am I
doing this like maybe this isn't gonna
work out and just like any other thing
that you learn you suck at the start
right learning how to operate a camera
learning how to ride a bike linen how to
garden right like the first time you do
anything you sock it takes you way
longer to figure it out and so that's
going to happen here too and the key
thing is that you keep doing it right
every every week I'd say at least one
video per week the people that I've seen
really grown
Oh start to amp it up they put out a
video a day just not even worrying about
the quality so much as getting better
like if you do it more I am way better
than I was when I started because I put
out two thousand videos and so the more
you do it the better you get the better
you get the better you get like riding
the bike like learning French you'll get
better every time you do it so be
consistent at least one a week and
ideally want a day to focus on helping
you get better so that's it those are
our seven tips thank you guys so much
for watching if you want to learn more
about Wichard where can we find you you
can find me on my youtube channel which
is right now my name Richard you gotta
love or my website which is you gotta
love calm and I'll put that right there
in the title or the credit and if you
guys have any questions on how to get
started with YouTube or you want to
share your experiences leave it in the
comments below and we will both join in
on that discussion sounds good thank you
guys so much for watching continue to
believe and you'll see you soon